so you have trump out of office you've
got biden in there
let's do the first 100 days will be oh
how refreshing it is
we now have a real president there and
they'll fluff everything up
and then what i have a feeling on this
show we're going to be like day two
joe biden has bombed 17 kids again and
then the media is going to be like
if we could even find out about it
because of all the censors
of all the legitimate news uh
organizations that actually do talk
about american foreign policy
if you under if if you remember during
the presidential debates this wasn't
even a topic of
debate this wasn't even a topic of
discussion well they can't second one
yes
so we might not even know what's
happening outside because of all the
communications lines being controlled
and being censored
but what i think is going to happen is
going to be very fascinating because
these organizations these groups these
larger ideologies are predicated
on attacking on going after and being
offensive instead of defensive so
i truly do believe that after the first
hundred days after trump
they're gonna start eating their own
they're gonna start attacking each other
tearing each other to shreds
because all that's left is is them and
they're gonna find some kind of micro
microaggression they're gonna find some
kind of privilege they're going to find
something to to eat each other apart
because there's no one else to hit well
so they're already starting to go after
fox and
so my assumption is they're going to
continue to do that oh yeah
but you're right i think at some point
so cnn
brands themselves now they're just the
anti-trump network that's what they do
which is what
msnbc is supposed to do and msnbc is at
least honest
about their brand they're leaning
forward and cnn was lying
but now they're in direct competition
with a democratic
house senate and white house so
they're going to have to go after each
other you can go after
fox all you want it's not going to work
but i hear they want that you know it
was
at t on cnn now they want to sell jim
acosta
we'll just we'll just we'll just say
reassigned i won't say fired
uh what else is going on they canceled
the airport uh cnn airport is is gone as
of march
i think they realize that the only thing
that kept them floating was donald trump
yeah it was truly a glorious past four
years
of unhinged desperation screaming at the
top of their lungs about trump nonstop
that's what happened you open up cnn you
turn on cnn it's just everyone's
screaming and
trump without him i think they're going
to try the trumpism angle
trumpism or the problem is they've
already banned all these people
twitter purged the q anon people what
are they going to complain about so i
think you're right luke
they're going to start looking so here's
what happens they get rid of the right
what's left
moderates when the moderates are gone
liberals
and then there's going to be eating each
other like it's auroboros and then
from my kind of understanding i do see
elements of the far left getting
attacked first
because they're the most vocal ones but
the the institutional power
is amongst the the corporatist the
sellouts the establishment so
i think right after the moderates it's
definitely going to be the farther left
the kind of
not even i don't even i don't want to
say aoc because she's more establishment
now
than anything else but anyone kind of
representing these ideas i think it's
going to get the boot
but another interesting factor to really
kind of remember here
is that before donald trump was
president the mainstream media ratings
their viewership was
tanking going down and there's a
legitimate argument to make that donald
trump
saved the mainstream in fact saved cnn
saved all these these national media
organizations that actually were going
out of
out of work because people were saying
i'd rather watch the
i rather go on the internet and watch
people that look like me that talk like
me that are actually genuine
and not represented by these bigger
larger interests that just spew
talking points and narratives at me for
their political goal
he raised them as like undead they were
dying i won't let you fully die
i like to imagine jeff zucker at cnn
right now is like you know he's turning
the lights off he's
you know he's like you know pulling on
his shirt straightening his tie and
looking at the studios everyone leaves
and the doors close
and then he walks up to this giant
golden statue of donald trump tear comes
in his eye he wipes and he goes
thank you thank you you know i think
that probably won't happen but i was
imagining that the news media
probably would start to go after biden
if biden does something really
stupid because they want to put kamal in
office
so they'll wait until biden pulls the
trigger on too many drone bombs or
the the economy tanks and they can all
put it on biden
i don't think it's going to happen no no
not not the drone thing dude they will
never criticize a president for war
yeah they cheered on donald trump he
used to go after bush though
yeah he's a republican they're not going
to obama how many people
obama killed americans yeah obama
literally was like
uh that's an american uh blow them up
teenage
american citizens were assassinated by
the doctor well
more than one teenager i was one
teenager um i don't know i think i think
obama killed
i don't i think it's four americans but
specifically i can name two of them
anwar al-awlaki and abdul rahman
al-awlaki
it's a 16 year old american kid who was
vis he was from i think he was from
colorado
colorado he was trying to find out who
his father was and then he went traveled
to yemen
and obama ordered a drone strike on a
civilian uh cafe
in a country we're not it's it we're not
a war with yemen and then blew up a
civilian restaurant killing an american
citizen
and the media is like oops or i'm sorry
i said the media went to obama and he
went
it was a mistake and they were like good
enough for us pack it in boys we got an
answer a lot bye everybody
and then donald trump ordered the hit i
believe on the sister and then again
we didn't hear anything yeah no i know
and then you know when donald trump
becomes very aggressive with his
military the mainstream media cheers him
on
they applaud him they say it's beautiful
it's great he's showing the leadership
so they're not going to do that but
but i do think you have a good point ian
they'll find something else
as an excuse because they want kamala
they might yeah but i i don't think so
but like two or three years in
i think there's maybe a reason like
maybe now what will happen is
we have i think marjorie taylor green
says she wants to impeach biden on day
one yeah
maybe they'll go oh no oh he's oh geez
ah i guess we'll have to impeach and
convict bye bye
kamala yay there we go
no right right but i mean i can't
imagine joe biden finishing out his term
for for any reason
because primarily i mean first of all
he's an old guy but but not even just
that they wanted kamala
i i really do think they were trying to
prop up kamala until tulsi gabbard
dropped that nuke and it really really
was damaging and hard to get around
and so then she just disappears then joe
biden all of a sudden becomes the front
runner
and then he picks kamala i don't know we
heard the same exact thing about donald
trump he's not going to last
uh the four years he didn't even want it
he's definitely not going to run for
reelection
biden will make it the four year unless
there's some you know health issue that
we don't
know about he might he he's almost
certainly not going to be
the external president yeah that that
people might want or maybe they don't
want that why did so many
external being out there being in being
public facing
doing a whole bunch of speeches my sense
is he probably is not going to be that
president
after the first year i think they've
noted the cognitive decline and let's
not be dissing him
he's of age where that happens i think
he's going to be in a wheelchair they're
going to roll him into the sunroom with
a little blanket on his lap and he's
just going to
snore away in the sun look if that
happens though the whole point of joe
biden
was to get a calming force in the white
house
who can then make it easier for a
democrat the next time around
i think it's a bad strategy if they
think it's going to be kamala harris and
i think you're right i think they
intended it to be
and she did not perform nearly as well
as she was supposed to
let me ask someone why who who is this
political consultant that keeps telling
people like hillary clinton and kamala
harris to laugh inappropriately and
randomly
well and especially if you have the most
irritating and grating laughs
god bless them but you know it really is
there are some people who just have
really unorganic laughs because it's
fake
yeah and when it's fake it's really
really grating so just stop
it just tell them to be like normal
human being and you would have thought
that they would have picked that up
with hillary clinton who came off as
presidential
if you took away all the phony nonsense
that
yeah i just i honestly i just don't
understand that it was like you you've
got the worst stereotype type in the
world
let's have hillary clinton cackle all
the time yeah
botox too in like 2006 she wasn't all
botoxed up and then all of a sudden she
just got all
face jacked and then started is it it's
it's the equivalent
so because they i think they did it with
sarah palin too which is like
really lean into the small town mayor
thing and use all these
isms and it just it came off as a little
bit too
phony whereas joe biden regardless of
what you think about
his policies as a personality he's
likeable
he has a likable personality yeah i
don't trust it but it's a likable person
you're saying you didn't like hillary
clinton who had hot sauce
in her bag when asked about it on a
popular hip-hop radio show that didn't
work for you
or kamala harris who somehow managed to
listen to rap before it came out
yeah that was impressive or andrew today
who is at an exquisite beautiful store
talking about how he loves the bodegas
who left his bananas behind i don't know
if you've seen that cringy andrew yang
video today no
he left his bananas on the table he
bought him he left him there
he couldn't even peel or peel one and
then he's like yes guys and he was in
the most like amazing glorious story
that you could ever imagine he's like
this is a bodega it wasn't a buddy
what's funny about
the andrew yang running for mayor thing
is that his big campaign
you know policy has always been
universal basic income and now he's
proposing what i think may be the worst
iteration of it
which is it's like uh five hundred two
thousand dollars for low-income people
in new york
which i'm sorry i know it's cliche but
would just incentivize people
to not work because what happens when
you do things like this is someone could
be on the threshold and say
i better work a couple less hours
otherwise i'll get kicked off these
benefits
if that's i'm giving a you know a
generalization to what his plan is but
more importantly
he's been criticized because you know
theoretically
the plan could work at the federal level
because the fed can print and borrow
money
new york can't new york needs revenue so
where are you going to get this money to
just start giving out to new york
as the rich folks are fleeing right well
they might be bailed out
by biden's new 1.9 trillion dollar plan
that he's putting forward where he talks
about giving
tens of billions of dollars to states
who are who are
in need new york city has been in need
before kovid because of their
overspending
now that problem is exacerbated to
20-fold 100-fold because again as you
could as you said
all the people with means are leaving
the people who can't leave
are stuck there and they're literally
talking about changing all the office
buildings into apartment buildings
so who's going to want to live in a
place where there's no jobs
there's nowhere to work and you have the
highest taxes in
nearly all of the united states joe
biden's plan as part of his new 1.9
trillion is an increase
of the federal minimum wage to 15 an
hour so across the board
everywhere you could be in the the you
know the uh
oklahoma panhandle and make very little
money well
good news fifteen dollars an hour for
everybody yeah all businesses have it
i mean they all have that money just on
stamp of course of course they're just
hanging on to it
right exactly it's uh you know leftists
totally get this
that all businesses everywhere at ever
at any given moment
have millions of dollars just sitting in
a bank account and that
well they're like dragons sitting atop
their pile of gold they just don't want
to give it to anybody
especially in rural america right right
so what we need is a valiant knight like
joe biden
to force those dragons to give up the
gold to the townspeople
problem solved is this for waiters too
that are making 213 in an hour getting
right they're getting rid of or they
want to get rid of the that wage
tip uh lower minimum wage which
because we did this in seattle and we
had these conversations
i you would be hard-pressed to find a
person who worked
at a restaurant who wanted that idea no
one wanted that they were like we make
so much more money under this current
system
and they ended up getting screwed i'm
down for not having a tip anymore
so so that plan went through and what
were the effects of it
so we're still learning the long-term
effects because this wasn't that long
ago but one thing that we definitely saw
happening was
hours were getting cut because they were
almost hitting that threshold where they
were
no longer able to get subsidies
but if they were to get off those
subsidies because they're now making 15
an hour now it's like 16 and 20
something cents it's still not enough
to live in seattle while at the exact
same time you have the seattle city
council and the mayor's office
constantly changing a whole bunch of
different programs
increasing taxes making it harder to
build homes and apartments
and so the cost of living continues to
go up so
it's it's ludicrous they just ended up
changing the way that uber rideshare
uh the rideshare model so now you have
to guarantee that they're making
a minimum wage on top of all these new
benefits
which uber came out and said okay but as
of right now we're now 25
more expensive to the customers by april
we expect it to be 40
and so far they're sticking it's way
more expensive that's good though
because the cab drivers don't like uber
yeah well that's of course that's really
what this is about but all the drivers
are like oh this is great we're going to
make so much more money
not if people don't take the uber
right and if they do take the uber it's
because they can now afford to take the
uber which means your city
is not appealing to the uh the the
diverse
diversity of a socio-economic background
you're now again catering to people
who can't afford to live in seattle
which is the exact opposite of what you
said you wanted to do
i got to point out the dark truth about
the restaurant industry uh waiters that
make three dollars an hour
will subsist off of cash tips that they
don't
declare and don't pay taxes on the
restaurant also does not have to declare
it or pay taxes on it
that's existed for the since probably
the beginning of time i love it
if they want to change that and start
forcing them to take salaries or huge
minimum wages and then no tips it's
going to destroy the restaurant industry
i know the irs probably doesn't like to
hear that irs but that's the way the
restaurant industry works
they get cash chips they don't decline i
don't think it'll destroy the restaurant
industry but i do think all current
weight staff
will get a very large red pill shove
down their throat when they're like
my income just dropped by 60 something
percent and the rest don't have to fire
them because they can't
front that money they're they're it's
tip money that they're they don't have
to pay
they'll increase the prices yeah and
then the way people won't come in and
then they won't be able to pay enough
waiters then not to cut back on their
waiters and they want enough servers to
serve the food their service will
decline
people will stop coming in it's just a
downward spiral it's kind of funny how
the politicians who promise to help
the poor people the most are actually
creating the most amount of poor people
and serving and catering the super rich
have you uh i think i think you've seen
this video luke but there's a viral
video
there's a video game it's called i
forgot it's called city state 2 maybe
and so there's this guy he plays the
games he makes youtube videos of his
games and then he publishes them
well it was a really funny moment where
he decided to create a city-state
that had no laws and he was like it's
going to be chaos it's going to be
murder and poverty
and so he was like no regulations free
market everything no taxes no support no
police
and then as he progresses through the
game there's zero poverty
every building is becoming a luxury high
rise and he's laughing he's like what's
happening everybody's rich there's no
protest there's no poverty there's no
crime why is this
and then a bunch of libertarians and
handcaps and conservatives are sharing
the video and they were like
progressive tries making a an uh
an anarcho-capitalist dystopia turns
into a utopia
so i'm not saying the video game is a
perfect model for the real world
but i do think it is important to point
out sometimes
actually kind of a lot of the time the
government tries to step
in thinking they're smart enough as a
committee
to alter the economy of an entire city
of millions of people
and that it's going to work i'm sorry
man look
i'm not a large fair capitalist by any
means i'm actually kind of left on
economic policy
but i can i can be the first to tell you
a decentralized network is going to be
smarter
and better at solving problems than a
committee than
a small group of people who can't see
the entire problem for what it is
well especially when you're in these
cities where it's kind of
one party rule i mean and that's the
same for conservatives
i imagine that if you had a large urban
city and it was only run by
conservatives you're running into
the same problems i do think you need
the person to tell you why they think
you're wrong
even if you ignore them the entire time
it does start getting into your head
and you do start to question some of
your own moves and i do think that that
ultimately leads to
better decisions but we've got so many
cities from new york
and seattle and portland and minneapolis
where that just does not exist and we've
seen
the consequences of city halls run that
way
i mean they're just unaccountable
one-party rule
districts that of course we have to
understand are laying the blueprints of
what most likely will happen on a
federal level
with of course the federal government
when we're talking about democrats
control of the senate
the the the congress the executive
office
we're we're seeing something that really
is going to truly shape the future of
this country
and now biden's going to be bailing out
all the
horrible mistakes all the horrible
decisions that they made
so what there's no incentive for them to
actually face reality and the
consequences of their horrible actions
because biden's just going to come in
and bail everyone out on and who's going
to pay for that
the people who didn't make the bad
mistakes the people who
conserve their money save their money
are now going to have to pay more taxes
and deal with more bull crap because of
other people's mistakes
i'm going to say the naughty words civil
war
and the reason why is what we're seeing
right now appears to be
a political civil war every four years
and it's been increasingly getting worse
2016 was insane trump wins they scream
russia the top of their lungs banging
their heads on the wall
rachel maddow is you know screaming
chris hayes
jonathan goes on msnbc and says trump
may have been an asset of the russians
since the 80s when they were part of the
soviet union it's just psychotic
nonsense
impeachment impeachment investigations
for years
every see what happens is they use every
political maneuver and every legal
maneuver they have to try and destroy
the other side now what's happening we
got marjorie taylor green on day one she
will she will file articles of
impeachment against joe biden
the democrats are now taking control of
the federal government in terms of the
senate and the house um
the senate the house and the executive
branch and then they're going to enact
laws
that large portions of the country does
not want the divide between the cultures
of how people
live are so dramatically different that
when you get
uh you know democrats in office it's
they're gonna what
these policies joe biden is proposing
especially gun control for instance
it makes no sense to raise the minimum
wage in rural oklahoma
and ban them from buying guns when they
live in the middle of nowhere why should
the law for new york city be the same as
this place it doesn't make sense that's
why the system we have
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you
all next time
you